قالت الخارجيه السودانيه انه تم الاتفاق
مع الجانب الاسرائيلي على المضي قدما في
تطبيع العلاقات بين البلدين وكان مجلس
سياده السوداني قد اكد ان رئيسه الفريق
عبد الفتاح البرهان التقى وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي
وتطرق معه لتعزيز العلاقات وافاق التعاون
بين البلدين في تطور يؤكد تنامي العلاقات
بين الخرطوم وتل ابيب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي دوافع الخرطوم
لتطبيع علاقاتها مع تل ابيب وما مغزى
توقيت هذه الخطوه وما المامول منها على
الصعيدين الداخلي والخارجي بالنسبه
للسودان في اي سياق فلسطينيا وعربي ياتي
انضمام السودان الى اتفاقات التطبيع خصوصا
في ظل ما تشهده الاراضي الفلسطينيه من
تصعيد غير مسبوق تمارسه حكومه يمنيه
متطرفه اثار استياء عربيا ودوليا والى اي
حد تنسجم هذه الخطوه مع استراتيجيه
نتنياهو التي ترى ان السلام مع
الفلسطينيين يجب ان ياتي بعد تطبيع
العلاقات مع الدول العربيه وهل تشكل هذه
الخطوه انقاذا لرئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
من مازيقه السياسي على ضوء التحديات
الداخليه التي يواجهها ومدى تاثير استمرار
مسار التطبيع الاسرائيلي مع الدول على
مسار حل القضيه الفلسطينيه وعلى مستقبل
دول المنطقه واستقرارها
[موسيقى]
منطلق وراء الستار بات اليوم في العلم
السودان على وشك توقيع اتفاق للتطبيع مع
اسرائيل لينضم بذلك الى نادي اتفاقات
ابراهام وما يؤكد ذلك هو زياره لوزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي كوهين الى الخرطوم
التي كان قد زارها من قبل عندما كان يشغل
حقيبه المخابرات في حكومه اسرائيليه سابقه
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه نقلت عن
مسؤولين اسرائيليين وصفهم الزياره
بالسياسيه والتاريخيه ناقله عن الوزير
الاسرائيلي تعهده بالكشف عن معلومات
وتفاصيل عن الزياره التي تبين التي تبين
ان السودان هو وجهتها من ناحيته اكد رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان تنام العلاقات والتعاون بين
السلطات العسكريه في الخرطوم والقيادات
الاسرائيليه قائلا ان التعاون السوداني
الاسرائيلي منصب على الجوانب الامنيه
والاستخباراتيه مشددا على ان ذلك التعاون
اثمر القبض على ما وصفه بالمجموعات
الارهابيه التي قال انها كانت تسبب مشاكل
للسودان والاقليم
[موسيقى]
للنقاش في هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم
اللواء محمد جمال الدين الخبير في الشؤون
الامنيه والاستراتيجيه وضيفنا من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
لحركه المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه مرحبا
بكما لواء محمد جمال الدين السودان اذا
الخارجيه السودانيه تقول انه تم الاتفاق
مع الجانب الاسرائيلي على المضي قدما في
تطبيع العلاقات ماذا يعني ذلك ماذا يعني
المضي قدما
طيب بسم الله والحمد لله والصلاه والسلام
على رسول الله
السلام عليكم الاخت الكريمه الكرام اهلا
وسهلا
حقيقه في اطار ما يجري الان يعني من
اتصالات مستمره منذ العام يعني عشرين
عشرين
هي يعني
هي اتصالات عاديه تمت التيم بصوره مستمره
ما بين السودان وبين ودوله اسرائيل
والسودان قد قد بدا هذه الخطوه عند التقاء
السيد رئيس المجلس الانتقالي الفريق
البرهان
رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي في اوغندا وكان الامر قد تم
بهذه بهذه السهوله وتم يعني الاتفاق على
ان يسير السودان في اطار التطبيق
والتطبيع يحتاج الى بعض الوقت يحتاج الى
بعض الخطوات التي من يعني تتم هذه المساله
بصوره المنطقيه وصوره السياسيه والصوره
الاجماع حتى على المستوى الادنى
الاسرائيليه لواء محمد جمال الدين تتحدث
عن ان السودان يستعد لتوقيع اتفاق التطبيع
يعني بشكل رسمي هل هل هذا ما ننتظره
نعم قد ننتظر هذا التطبيق بصوره رسميه
ولكن قد لا يكون غدا او بعد غدا هناك بعد
الخطوات
ستتم هناك بعض المنشورات حتى ستتم من هنا
وهناك ومن ثم اذا كان هناك مجالا للتوقيع
النهائي سيتم التوقيع عقب
الاتفاق الكلي عليه
مجمل القضايا ما بين الدولتين ما المنتظر
يعني ما هي القضايا التي يتم البحث بها
الان
للوصول الى توقيع الاتفاق النهائي
السودان الان به بعض الاشكالات التي تعلمي
جيدا انه السودان الان ليست هناك حكومه
منتخبة ولا حتى حكومه انتقاليه يمكن ان
تقرر بصوره نهائيه في اطار هذا الامر
الاستراتيجي الذي يعني دائما لا يتم الا
في الاطار
الشرعي بالنسبه لدوله او حكومه منتخبه او
حتى حكومه انتقاليه مجمع عليها من كافه
القوى السياسيه او العسكريه في السودان
وبالتالي هذه خطوه مباركه وهذه خطوه في
الاطار الصحيح والسودان يسعى لاعاده يعني
وضع نفسي في المجتمع الدولي من خلال
التمدد في علاقاته الدوليه ومن ضمن هذه
العلاقات العلاقات مع اسرائيل وهذا امر
عادي ويحتاج الامر الى بعض الخطوات انا
افتكر هذه الخطوات ليست بالخطوات
السهل ايضا ولكن امر التطبيع وامر التوقيع
يعني هو من ضمن الاشياء التي تم الاتفاق
عليها ما بين
الحكومتين من فتره سابقه حتى تكون الامور
اوضح بالنسبه لنا ماذا يريد ان يحقق
السودان من وراء اتفاق تطبيع مع اسرائيل
حتى لو لم يكن هذا الاتفاق سيحصل غدا كما
قلت
نعم السودان يحتاج الى تعزيز موقفه
الامني والاستراتيجي والمخابرات يعني ضمن
دول الطوق الموجوده في هذا المحيط الذي
نعيش فيه الان في هذه المنطقه التي يعني
في شمالها لنا بعض الاشكالات وفي شرقها
عندنا كثير من الاشكالات وفي غرب بها
اشكالات وفي الجنوب اشكالات نحن نعاني من
هذه الاشكالات ونتوقع ان تدخل علينا بعض
المهددات الامنيه
العابره للاقليم التي قد تهدد يعني
واضحه بشكل اكبر سمي لنا ما هي المشاكل
هذا التي تريد ان يواجهها وكيف من شان
اتفاق تطبيع مع اسرائيل ان يساعده في هذه
المواجهه
نعم انا افتكر نحن نواجه في
قد نواجه في الفتره القريبه القادمه ببعض
الخلايا النائمه والخلايا الارهابيه التي
قد تاتي الى السودان ومن ثم تنطلق يعني من
السودان الى دول اخرى وقد تحدث كثير من
الضجي يعني داخل السودان وهذه الخلايا انت
تعرفينها هي خلايا ارهابيه يعني سواء كانت
هي تابعه للقاعده او التابعه لي يعني يعني
الدوله الاسلاميه وانصار الدين او كل هذه
الخلايا المسمى وانت تعرفين جيدا نحن
نحتاج ان نؤمن السودان نحتاج ان يكون
لدينا شركاء على مستويات متعدده
يعني كيف من شان اتفاق تطبيع بين السودان
واسرائيل ان يساعد السودان على مواجهه
هكذا تحديات امنيه مع القاعده او تنظيم
الدوله
[موسيقى]
نعم تقويه العلاقات الامنيه والمخابراتيه
والعسكريه ياتي في اطار التوامه
والتدريبات المشتركه ما بين الدولتين ونحن
سنستفيد من اسرائيل في يعني في في هذا
الاطار ليس اسرائيل فقط انما اسرائيل
واولئك الذين ايضا يدعمون اسرائيل
وشركائها في هذا المجال بالنسبه لنا هذا
مجال حيوي ونريد ان نتعامل فيه مع كافه
الدول ومن بين هذه الدول ايضا اسرائيل
دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي هل تجد مبررات
لتطوير العلاقات بين السودان واسرائيل
وصولا الى توقيع اتفاق التطبيع بينهما
اطلاقا لا يوجد اي مبررات وانا اعتبر انه
من المستهجن والمشين في الواقع لاي دوله
ان تطبع مع اسرائيل مع اي حكومه ان تطبع
مع اسرائيل وفي هذه الحكومه الفاشيه
المتطرفه عنصريا والمجرمه
والتي يعني الجميع يقر بانها اكثر
الحكومات عنصريه وتطرفا واجراما ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني وبشكل عام في المنطقه
وترتكب المجازر ضد الشعب الفلسطيني انا
متاكد ان الشعب السوداني باسره يرفض مثل
هذا الامر
والشعب السوداني شعب اصيل شعب بطل شعب
مناضل شعب كان دائما للقضيه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه ولحق الشعوب في التحرر ولذلك
انا استغرب جدا مثل هذا التطبيع الذي يجري
وان كان يدل على شيء فهو يدل على ان
اسرائيل نجحت في ابتزاز السودان اسرائيل
تامرت على السودان من خلال مؤامراتها في
جنوب السودان واسرائيل تامرت على السودان
ومصر مع اثيوبيا من اجل قطع مياه النيل
واسرائيل ربما تفتعل وجود مجموعات يسمونها
مجموعات ارهابيه من اجل ان تبتز السودان
وتدفعه لمثل هذه العلاقات ولكن بدون شك
هناك دور امريكي في اللعبه
وهذا يؤكد ان اداره بايدن ممعنه في تنفيذ
ما بداه ترامب وهو صفقه القرن بالتطبيع مع
المحيط العربي على حساب القضيه الفلسطينيه
ولطعن الظاهر الشعب الفلسطيني في ظهره
ومحاوله لعزل وتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه
ولكن كل ذلك لا ينجح انا متاكد ان كانت
هناك انتخابات ديمقراطيه حره في السودان
وانتخبت حكومه ديمقراطيه اول شيء ستفعله
ستلغي مثل هذا الاتفاق لانه يتعارض مع
مشاعر وقيم واخلاق الشعب السوداني
ونحن ناسف انه حكومات تتورط في مثل هذه
الاتفاقات وخاصه مع في هذا الوقت بالتحديد
الذي نطالب فيه العالم باسره وكل من يحترم
حقوق الانسان بمقاطعه اسرائيل عليها دكتور
مصطفى ولكن ربما البعض يجاوب على ما تتفضل
به بان السودان بدا بهذا المسار مسار
التطبيع مع اسرائيل لانه كان يريد ان يتم
رفع اسمه عن قائمه الارهاب الامريكيه وهذا
امر هذه السلطه الحاليه اليوم في السودان
ليست مسؤوله عنه هي تتعامل مع تداعياته
التي ورثتها من السلطات السابقه وما كان
بالامكان فعل اي شيء الا المضي قدما في
هذا المسار كيف يرد على هذا الكلام
يرد عليه بانه اللعبه واضحه طبعا الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل تتشاركان معا في وضع
الدول في مسار يعني تصنف فيه كرهابيه او
مسار عقوبات ثم يجري ابتزازها لكي تنشئ
علاقات مع اسرائيل وحتى علاقات
استخباراتيه انا احذر الاخوه السودانيين
ان علاقاتهم الاستخباراتيه مع اسرائيل
ستجعلهم يعني فريسه بالكامل للجانب
الاسرائيلي مثلما جرى مع حكومات عربيه
اخرى يعني دخول الانظمه الاستخباراتيه
الاسرائيليه للسودان سيجعل كل ما هو مع كل
معلومات السودان بيد الاسرائيليين وانا
برايي هذا مسار خاطئ مضر بالسودان قبل ان
يكون مدور مدرا بشعب الفلسطيني وان كان
ايضا مدرا بالشعب الفلسطيني ويستخدم
نتنياهو وهو قال ذلك في مقابله مع السيان
ان امس قال بكل وضوح وصراحه ان مساره هو
التطبيع مع العرب لعزل الفلسطينيين
ومن ثم محاوله استعباد الفلسطينيين في
نظام ابارتايد وتمييز عنصري يسميه
السلام العملي شو يعني السلام العملي يعني
اخضاع محاوله اخضاع الفلسطينيين وهذا لن
ينجح لا اتفاقات التطبيع مع الامارات
ومع البحرين اثرت في نضالنا بالعكس ازداد
هذا النضال قوه وازداد عزما وعزيمه ولا
مثل هذه الاتفاقيات ستؤثر في نضالنا ولكن
نحن نتوجه للشعب السوداني الشقيق الشعب
السوداني الذي كان دائما مع فلسطين ان يقف
في وجه هذا التطبيع وان يرفضه وان يفرض
المقاطعه والعقوبات على اسرائيل لواء محمد
الم يكن من الممكن الاستغناء عن هذا
اللقاء بين رئيس مجلس السياده ووزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي في هذا التوقيت
تحديدا بينما يواجه الفلسطينيون كل هذا كل
هذه الضغوط من الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
انا ارى اختي الكريمه انه لا ندير في ان
يلتقي سيدنا رئيس مجلس السياده يعني بوزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي في اطار العلاقات
العاديه
وهذا اذا اذا ما تم انا يعني لا ارى ان
هناك اشكالا كبيرا قد حدث وان انه تم يعني
تم التعرض
للحديث السالب عن عن القضيه الفلسطينيه
هذا يتعارض مع كليه مع مع المنطق في
السودان ومع يعني مع الموقف السوداني تجاه
القضيه الفلسطينيه هذا امر يعني يجب
رساله ضد المصالح الفلسطينيه
لا لا ارى ان هناك هناك يعني اي اي حسابات
ضد يعني ضد الموقف
الفلسطيني نحن كشعب في السودان نحيف
فلسطين وندافع عن فلسطين ونتحدث عنها يعني
كما تعلمين من ضمن من ضمن بعيد بكل تلك
المشاعر الكبيره اتجاه الشعب الشقيق في
فلسطين ولكن هذا لا يمنع السودان يقيم
علاقات مع الدول الاخرى ايا كانت هذه
العلاقات سواء كانت مع اسرائيل لو مع
امريكا او مع
محمد هذه الدوله محتله تمارس البارتايد
بحق الفلسطينيين كما يقول تقول منظمات
الدوليه
انت انت اذا اردت ان تحل شيئا يجب ان
يكونوا هناك حوارا مع الطرف الذي
الذي يعني تتداخل معه
وتتشاكس معه وتتجادل معه لا يمكن ان اذا
كانت نقطه مهمه لواء محمد واضح ذكرت نقطه
مهمه لواء محمد ان لا يمكن توقيع الاتفاق
لان اتفاق تطبيع بين السودان واسرائيل في
هذه المرحله لان السلطه في السودان حاليا
هي في مرحله انتقاليه ان كان الامر كذلك
على اي اساس باعتقادك اتخذ رئيس المجلس
مجلس السياده اللواء عبد الفتاح البرهان
هذا القرار بلقاء وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي في هذا التوقيت بينما كما ذكرت
السلطه هي في مرحله انتقاليه والجيش يتعهد
بان يترك السلطه المدنيين
انا اريد ان اقول الاتي انه ما يجري ما
بين السودان واسرائيل
لم يبدا اليوم انه بدا من قبل ثلاث سنوات
وهناك كثير من الاشياء التي تجري بين
الدولتين وكثير من الزيارات المتبادله
التي تمت ما بين يعني السودان
واسرائيل وهذه هي احدى احدى هذه
الزيارات التي كانت يعني تم تم الاتفاق
عليها مسبقا فلا ارى لماذا هذا كل الضجيج
يعني ان نلتقي السيد يعني السيد رئيس
الانتقالي في هذا اللقاء مع مع رئيس
وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيليه لماذا كل هذا
الضجيج دكتور مصطفى لماذا كل هذا الضجيج
من الخداع للنفس بالنسبه
لضيفك من الخداع للنفس ان يعتقد انه من
الممكن انشاء علاقات مع من يبطشون بالشعب
الفلسطيني
ويضطهدون الشعب الفلسطيني وهو نتنياهو
تحديدا وحكومته العنصريه ينشئ معها علاقات
وهي تبطش بالشعب الفلسطيني ثم يقول هو
يدعم قضيه الشعب الفلسطيني هذا مستحيل هذا
تناقض هذا غير منطقي وخاصه ان نتنياهو
يستعمل علاقات التطبيع هذه لمحاصره القضيه
الفلسطينيه ويعلن ذلك اعلنه امس على السي
ان ان انه يريد ان يحاصر الفلسطينيين
بعلاقات التطبيع مع المحيط العربي لذلك
هذا الكلام لا منطقه فيه ودعيني اقول بكل
وضوح وصراحه التطبيع مع حكومه اسرائيل
العنصريه الفاشيه حكومه بنجفير ونتنياهو
هو امر مشين ومخزي وخيانه للشعب الفلسطيني
وقضيته الوطنيه بكلمات واضحه وصريحه واكثر
من ذلك هو اساءه لمصالح الشعب السوداني
وانا اؤكد ان ما يجري يضر بمصالح الشعب
السوداني قبل ان يضر بمصالح الشعب
الفلسطيني واعيد واكرر اذا اتيح للشعب
السوداني ان تكون له حريه انتخابيه
وديمقراطيه حقيقيه فسيلغي هذه الاتفاقات
بالكامل لانه الافضل والاصح والسليم ان
يكون الى جانب الشعب الفلسطيني ضد هذه
الحكومه الفاشيه وضد ما يتعرضه الشعب
الفلسطيني من تهويد وضم وتنكيل وقتل يجري
على مدار الساعه الشعب الفسوداني يجب ان
يكون الى جانب الشعب الفلسطيني ويجب ان
يوقف هذه المهزله التي اسمها تطبيع مع هذا
الكيان الفاشل الدكتور مصطفى اريد ان
اسالك يعني في ختام هذه الحلقه ما
انعكاسات هكذا تقارب وتطبيع توقيع اتفاق
تطبيع محتمل بين السودان واسرائيل في هذه
المرحله اولا على مسار الحل في القضيه
الفلسطينيه لانك ذكرت ان اتفاقيات التطبيع
لم تؤثر على نضال الفلسطيني ولكن اريد ان
افهم انعكاس على مسار الحلول وايضا
انعكاسها على حكومه نتنياهو
هي لا تؤثر على تصميم الشعب الفلسطيني
ونضاله من اجل حقوقه الوطنيه بالتاكيد كما
لم تؤثر اتفاقيات اخرى والدليل على ذلك ما
نراه الان في تصاعد النضال الوطني
الفلسطيني ولكن هي تشجع نتنياهو وتقوي
حكومه نتنياهو التي تواجه معارضه
اسرائيليه شديده الان
ومعارضه قويه تريد ان تسقط هذه الحكومه
لذلك هذا تشجيع للحكومه العنصريه والفاشيه
وتشجيع ايضا للاتجاهات في الولايات
المتحده التي تسير على نهج ترامب بمحاوله
توسيع التطبيع مع اسرائيل على حساب القضيه
الفلسطينيه وفي اطار محاصرتها لكن هل هذا
سيوقف نضالنا بالتاكيد لا انا كنت اتمنى
لو ان الحكومات هذه الحكومات التي تطبع مع
اسرائيل مثل حكومه السودان الان تقتدي بما
تفعله حكومه جنوب افريقيا
تقتدي بما تفعله حكومه الجزائر هؤلاء
يقفون مع الحق لانه حق ومع مصالح الشعوب
وحقوقها ويع انا استغرب جدا ان ابناء
جلدتنا العرب يسير في هذا الاتجاه اشكركما
جزيل الشكر دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
العام لحركه المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
ضيفا من رام الله واللواء محمد جمال الدين
الخبير في الشؤون الامنيه والاستراتيجيه
ضيفنا من الخرطوم
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]